hello freak [ __ ] and I figured out
but Bisping is said that if GSP can't
make it by July he'll fight somebody
else so he might fight Michael Bisping
blasts Joe Rogan and Nick Diaz for
positively promoting cannabis doja but
that might not be real like you know by
saying blasts you'd have to hear like
what he actually said I can't tell what
it's from it is it's all clickbait
nowadays so you might have just seen
that it might have literally and I
probably hanging out with Joe Rogan you
know you see that that's 60 minutes on
and all that you know I know his words
it's a good book thank you fake news or
whatever you see the yeah 60 minutes on
it technologies oh yeah I mean you know
I've like them that words sort of
popular now yes I think I don't know
some people have said it and popular but
it's it's a it's amazing now all the
people profiting on it it really
showcases you check out the 60 minutes
we we've had it do you remember the you
saved me from a bear attack oh yeah
there was yeah you know I got attacked
by a bear Joe shot the bear and there's
a whole article yeah that's all it was I
got one that said I killed a mountain
lion with my belt that's right Pasadena
right yeah do you mean what do you think
about that that you think there's it's a
I mean all that stuff is pretty do you
think there should be controls over it
like just outside of being you know the
FCC being able to sue people or whatever
that never really happens it feels like
do you think that it should I don't know
like things like the onion it's like
when do you draw the line because the
onion is hilarious oh they'll make it
like a subtle parody of something and
make it completely preposterous right
and then like pull up a good example of
an onion headline there's like onion do
you don't know what the onion is now the
onion is a famous parody news site where
they make stories that just if you're
smart you read it you go what next to
little bear or something to make is
making
inheriting on yeah yeah in a way yeah
yeah and most of them are pretty
humorous but occasionally people will
tweet me with like an onion story and
like [ __ ] believe this [ __ ] man it's
getting out of control
dummy this is this is comedy they're
writing people don't have common sense
so that's a problem with that quick base
stuff is they believe it yeah cuz they
don't they can't read it and be like
that's probably whatever it's just like
they believe everything yeah but it mean
isn't that the case with like cults and
the Moonies and Scientology and like
there's a lot of nonsense that people
believe in it's not hard to get people
to believe in [ __ ] sure it's a good
question like what do we do about it do
you leave it up to common sense which
isn't very common today or do you do
step in yeah rookie justice Gorsuch how
do you say his name assigned to Supreme
Court overnight shift that's a joke see
because he's a new Supreme Court guy and
they're giving him a shitty gig see
that's not real but if somebody read
that they're like this is [ __ ] these
[ __ ] liberals they're just because
he's a conservative they're putting it
on the night yeah there's no night shift
man tries using pink six pound bowling
ball to great amusement that's not real
either see like it's like what they do
they write these articles that are
comedy but they fake they pose as news
which is a little I think it's different
cuz right if you have you know if your
fiction and you're posing as as real
news yeah yeah it's like where do you
where you know if like there's no more
journalistic integrity it feels it feels
like there's some there's some there's
some it just feels like there's a you
know it's a and you how do you know how
do you Eddie you know you you read the
news
you misinformed you don't read it you're
misinformed
you're not informed he's like well you
know what do you do so have you been the
topic of something oh I mean no there's
I mean there's been fake stuff about me
yeah sure oh yeah my setting my dad
saying I believe half of what you see
and then what you hear I always laugh
cuz probably some silly thing my friends
will come to me and say hey do you
really do this no I didn't do that yes a
ton of fake stuff out there
a ton of fiction about you oh yeah yeah
I just won recently by disarmed a guy at
the comedy store some guy had a gun and
I disarmed it my buddy minor cops at a
man congratulations on that good job
dude like what good job what did I do
you saved you save people's lives but
you can ruin someone's life you know in
a second yeah it's um the wrong word
some you know someone says he you know
like I throw is allegedly or something
sure they legibly raped somebody or
something you know they ruin some poor
guy's life you know reputation just out
the out the window well that's what
they've always been able to do with
those supermarket tabloids say allegedly
from a source a source tells us the
campaigns likes to be careful you don't
have to do much more than that and you
kind of cover your ass and you say I
have to protect my sources a First
Amendment right and yes it's a weird
time it's a weird time because
essentially the boundaries to
publication have been dissolved it used
to be that you had to work for the New
York Times or The Washington Post or a
newspaper whatever
now you just all you need is a blog or a
Facebook page and you're breaking news
you know and just Scott Eastwood admits
to you know wearing women's clothes
while you're hunts for deer it's David
it's strange
it's definitely you're right it's
definitely change but I mean but who's
to decide I mean I know they're trying
to work on some ways to figure it out I
know Facebook is working on some
different ways to block fake news but
who's to decide what's fake and what's
real and who's to decide where it
becomes parody when is it funny like
when is it the onion when it's pretty
subtle sure and when is it just like
some guy making up a story about you me
saving you from a bear attack yeah and
it's weird I don't know
Ronald sweater f-1 yeah and I'm really
I'm really concerned yeah yeah yeah I
mean I'll sleep all night
okay but it's a weird sign of the times
the times are weird yeah we have weird
times and this the ability to
communicate where anybody can do
anything at any time
everybody could find out about it like
you can write something on your Twitter
page just publish it and then it gets to
the right amount of people and then they
share it and then all sudden a million
people have seen it inside of an hour
and they serve them now it's crazy but
it's POW as it's good too
I mean we've used that for our benefit
yes which is what you do all the time
always what I do your voice I mean it's
this made you have a vote or me have a
voice you know you've always had one but
me have one and so it's it's an amazing
time to well even my voice is way
different now I'm having a podcast and
that's a month much in a lot of ways the
same thing because it's just I mean this
is a pretty lean operation obviously I
just stayed surprised just a computer
you know Jamie - yeah figure it out and
then we talk and then yeah you upload it
that's it yeah so there's not many steps
and yet this will probably get five
million downloads you know maybe even
more so it's weird
yeah it's weird in that sense that it
can reach so many different people and
then it's there's there's no corporation
behind that there's no Washington Post
so we could just sit here just make up a
bunch of fake [ __ ] yeah and just be
really adamant that this really happened
and you know we're gonna believe it well
yeah yeah and how could could someone
stop you from doing that I don't know if
they could you know as long as you're
not slandering anybody and you're not
getting sued
[Applause]
[Music]